it sounds like they definitely did
because your initial kickstarter goal
was at 50,000 and you end up raising
over 84 mm-hmm I mean that's nowadays
you're seeing and even a year ago it has
gotten tougher what seems like has it
gotten has it gotten top right I
imagined it would yeah it seems like it
has because that sort of honeymoon phase
if crowdfunding is kind of going on yeah
yeah so I mean that's that's pretty
amazing to not only reach such a high
amount but then to go over like that I
think a lot of it was we were
pre-selling the DVD and and because
people really wanted to see the film so
that worked out really well but yes they
were incredibly supportive we were we
couldn't believe it fascinating i think
it's a it's really interesting just as a
thinking about it i think it i think
peter broderick talks about it it's not
as not just a it's not just a
fundraising thing it's also a PR thing
so you have to think about it as you
know a great way to get the word out
about your film whether or not people
are donating that I think that's a
really interesting element of it and and
then the question of timing like do you
do it at the beginning to get it off the
ground or in the case of film like do
you wait until you're at that you know
you've got a film you've got something
that people can get behind it looks very
solid and real and tangible and and
doable and exciting and then ask people
to help to contribute still knowing that
DVDs are at least a year away I mean
that actually has been one of the more
difficult management issues is that
everybody you know people understand
they can get behind Kickstarter but they
may not understand that like it takes a
long time for a DVD to come out you know
they don't understand
the way that films are typically
distributed and they don't necessarily
understand like the work that has to go
into getting something you know so like
dealing with the audience saying like
where's my DVD when's that coming out
yeah I know all of that no matter how
clearly you try to say it it's like you
know we also waited to put out our
trailer until the Kickstarter campaign
started so you know on Facebook we said
our trailers finally here you know click
through to Kickstarter to see it
probably good that you know so that was
great because people were wanted to see
the trailer and then they were at the
Kickstarter say and that that worked
well I think for us I don't know there
are lots of its it worked out really
well versus we were so grateful what's a
trick to keeping a passionate audience
happy because I'm sure with passion
there's you know people ecstatic about
it but then there's also that you know
questioning where is something and also
may be needing constant attention
sometimes you know I think you just that
it's just staying on top of the
conversation and getting back to people
and being personal being you know the
personal attention I think we try to
rape everybody back I mean we really try
to right everybody back um I mean
usually that works out really well
usually it is hard because there's
expectations
don't yeah but I also feel like these
people have been invested in the project
yes they gave money at the you know when
we were doing the Kickstarter and the
film has come out and it's done well and
it got some positive reviews and that
then they feel part of it and and they
it seems like people like the film to
thank goodness but um it's you know then
they tell their friends because it's
like oh I was a part of this yeah and
it's so exciting and the emails that we
get it's like you know to just print
them out and stick them on the bulletin
board they're so so many beautiful
emails like thoughtfully written and
like lovingly crafted and it just is
like the greatest it's it's the greatest
thing ever that people feel invested in
the film and are rooting it on and care
about it it's it's so sustaining it
really is
you